this video is brought to you by raycon
[Music]
what's up guys helen here to talk about
your favorite brooding masked crusader
yep batman's back complete with the film
noir inspired aesthetic to go with all
his emo feelings fittingly the batman is
all about playing with lightness and
darkness both visually and thematically
specifically it's exploring which of
gotham's hidden truths are exposed to
the light and which remains shrouded in
darkness and lies so pull out those
double a batteries and get your
flashlight ready for this wisecrack
quick take on the batman how much truth
can one society handle and of course
spoilers ahead for the new batman
but before we get into it i want to tell
you about this video's sponsor recon
raycon's everyday earbuds look sleek and
bring high sound quality to everything i
listen to whether it's music podcasts or
the haunted house sound effects i
require to fall asleep at night plus
they're comfortable to wear thanks to
optimized gel tips that adapt to the
contours my ears this design helps them
stay put no matter what even if you're
exercising or in my case telling the
wisecrack team that i will not practice
tick tock dances while the camera is
rolling raycon's everyday earbuds offer
8 hours of playtime and a 32 hour
battery life so you can get through an
entire work day of zoom calls without
worrying they'll cut out and that's just
one of the reasons they have more than
48 thousand five star reviews another
reason raycon's everyday earbuds offer
quality audio at half the price of other
premium brands click the link in the
description or go to buy rakon.com
wisecrack to get 15 off your purchase
that's by
raycon.comwisecrack to get 15 off now
back to the show now the batman shows
gotham as a city where lies and
concealment are so common they're
practically part of the infrastructure
on a most obvious level there's batman's
steadfast refusal to reveal his identity
to anyone even to a fellow leather
enthusiast who are you under there but
the shadowy edges of gotham are brought
into sharp focus by the film's also
masked villain the riddler he repeatedly
states his grand project to shine a
light on all the city's lies he's
targeting the rich and powerful for
their various deceits which range from
funding sketchy nightclubs to faking a
giant drug bust and the most egregious
deceit is also the most widespread the
city's elite have straight up looted the
gotham renewal fund which the wayne
family established to help clean up the
town and by the time we get to the
film's final big reveal that a mafia s
kingpin is puppeteering gotham's entire
government it's clear that these widely
accepted lies go all the way to the top
all this deceit from the city's rich and
powerful made us think of plato's
concept of the noble lie as explored in
a controversial paragraph of his book
the republic he explains that rulers
will need a throng of lies and
deceptions for the benefits of the ruled
basically a noble lie is an untruth that
a society's leaders use to persuade
their citizens to fall into line all in
the name of keeping their society
functioning a common noble lie is that a
given country's land inherently belongs
to its people even if that land was
actually stolen a simple way of thinking
of a noble lie is the way parents might
be dishonest with their child for their
own good plato basically thought that
such lies could be justified if they
served moral ends and means modern
philosophers like leo strauss have
endorsed noble lies as necessary for
social cohesion it's good to keep people
united in their ideology even if that
ideology is falsely constructed and we
see a pretty perverted version of the
noble lie in the batman where a
government filled with apparently good
honest leaders is revealed to be a giant
masquerade these leaders have long
pretended to be genuinely invested in
gotham's renewal when in actuality the
wayne funds were treated as a cash grab
for corruption the not so noble lie that
thomas wayne's funds are being used to
help the city flourish couldn't be
further from the truth gotham's
politicians get to blame the city's
criminal underworld for all the crime
and economic problems while all the
while working alongside those very
criminals to ensure that they're both
making money hand over fist and it's
effective the smoke and mirrors of the
gotham renewal project and the lingering
specter of the criminal underworld have
kept the people distracted while the
select few continue to enjoy their money
and power the lie has arguably fostered
social cohesion although probably not as
effectively as say actually investing in
your city's infrastructure and social
services but hey i digress and
throughout the movie we see more noble
lies but on a smaller scale for example
we learned that batman's dad went to
great lengths to maintain his wife's
reputation eventually this led him to
send a seedy crime boss to intimidate an
investigative reporter who was going to
publish a story about the less savory
details of his wife's personal history
as usually happens when you hire your
local crime boss for a freelance gig but
this resulted in murder all of which is
sounding not super noble in tandem with
this revelation we also see that
batman's vision of his father as the
ultimate pinnacle of human goodness has
too been a noble lie alfred admits that
he didn't tell batman the truth about
his father because he knew little bruce
desperately needed to believe in his
dad's unimpeachable greatness here it's
worth noting a choice that strikes us as
the movie's biggest shortcoming it's
refusal to double down on soluting the
image of thomas wayne see at first
batman thinks that his dad intended to
have the reporter killed a horrifying
prospect that would tarnish thomas's
legacy however he quickly learns that
all thomas wanted to do was scare the
reporter rather than kill him all in the
name of protecting his wife what's more
thomas was racked with guilt in the
aftermath of the murder in fact alfred
even says that thomas was planning to go
to the police and that this may have
been the reason he himself was killed
this felt like a bit of a cop-out and a
missed opportunity to really complicate
the wayne legacy in an interesting way
importantly making thomas wayne a
capital b bad guy would have created
some nice mirroring in the two threads
of the plot we'd have to watch batman
personally reckon with the same thing
the city of gotham is on a larger scale
the fact that the people they admired
most were actually super sus and
blatantly immoral instead it's like
everybody else got santa spoiled for
them while batman just found out that
santa made one really bad choice in the
80s so what happens when noble lies
become intrinsic to a given society's
functioning kind of like your
increasingly elaborate explanation about
why you got home late from school which
had nothing at all to do with the eight
bong ribs at corey's house lies tend to
get more lies a lie then about the
city's biggest drug bust then begets
another lie that the busted drug ring
has been shut down when in actuality
it's continued to flourish by bribing
public officials and as the riddler
reveals the total dishonesty of each
public figure he starts to show how this
cycle of deceit has eaten away at the
foundation of gotham civil society by
the end of the film we learned that just
about every powerful person employed by
the city of gotham has accommodated the
lies and corruption necessary to
maintain their power so obviously the
rich and influential are super duper
guilty although certainly not deserving
of having their faces devoured by rats
but by the end the riddler becomes even
more radical suggesting that all of
gotham is culpable for blindly accepting
the lies fed to them by politicians and
thus are complicit in the creation of
this deceitful society the film itself
reflects some sense of communal
responsibility showing the solemn
beginning of a funeral for the mayor
where presumably nobody was planning to
mention those leaked photos of him with
the young woman who had been battered
but when ridler escalates his attack to
target the entire city of gotham things
start feeling a little religious and not
just because the song ave maria pops up
at least twice in the film see by the
riddler's estimation the sins of the
city's leaders and consequently its
people are too heinous for gotham
society to ever be redeemed that's why
he decides to flood the whole place
ironically by destroying some of the
city's actually functional
infrastructure this can't help but make
us think of the old testament god and
the whole flooding the goddamn world
because people were behaving immorally
thing as if it wasn't harsh enough god
additionally reigned burning sulfur on
the city of sodom specifically for the
reason the riddler floods gotham it was
a corrupt place that failed to use its
resources to take care of its most
vulnerable citizens these evocations are
anything but subtle and don't even get
us started on the whole sins of the
father theme throughout the movie too
but back to the riddler he's a bad guy
for a reason where he sees an
unredeemable society or an unredeemable
family batman sees something else
entirely to understand let's track
batman's personal arc in the film he
starts off really stoked on the idea of
vengeance believing that the best way to
keep people safe is by a giving them
something to fear and b making sure
people are held accountable for their
actions with violence he might not be
drowning an entire city but this
approach is not unlike the riddler's old
testament vibes but throughout the film
this approach to making society a better
place is called into question not the
least of which when the riddler tells
batman that he has been an essential
player in the villain's deranged plot
and even says that they are basically
teammates but the validity of vengeance
as a guiding moral compass is called
into question most explicitly when
batman faces off against the riddler
snipers who have been shooting into a
crowd one of the snipers when asked his
name replies vengeance thus mirroring
batman's ideology back at him obviously
sharing the same mantra as a banana's
group of snipers isn't a good look so
it's no surprise that our hero
ultimately settles on a different view
he decides that rather than needing
someone to fear the people of gotham
really need someone to believe in
someone to inspire hope and as he saves
people from the riddler's giant flood
batman becomes that guy in the process
he also reads kind of like a jesus
figure to the riddler's old testament
god the brave guy willing to make
enormous sacrifices and even risk death
in order to redeem a world filled with
sinners someone who wants justice more
than he does vengeance the answer's
justice but what do you guys think can
noble lies be a justifiable way to keep
any given society humming along would
you rather not know just how deeply
corrupt the rich and powerful are let us
know in the comments big old thanks to
our patrons for all your support and be
sure to check out our podcast punch that
subscribe button like it's a corrupt
civil servant profiteering off a local
drug crisis and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you